hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything that
pops into my head while i'm watching
anime i'm grand line waifu your resident
nerdy psychologist and today we are
going deep
into the dark web to watch the hive mind
of the hunter kids as they decide to go
into home with a random man who tells
two young boys that it's dangerous if
they go further and do they want to of
course they do
it's dangerous alright let's get into
episode 82
of hunter hunter 82 and i know i
regularly comment on god's musculature
developing
now that he's not wearing any form of
sleeved shirt we're seeing that physical
shift in him from pre-teen to pre-teen
with muscles kilwa we never really know
about because he does everything he can
to hide his presumably pallid skin from
view
every episode for the moment we're being
teased with the concept of gone killing
someone then having it taken away from
us
even when he attempted to kill someone
and perhaps had started to deal with the
implications of that leaving himself
vulnerable to attack himself
it was still taken away from us by
comparison we got to see kilwa's killer
instincts return in the form of a new
ability or
an old one returned to us there's
something both heartbreaking and
wonderful about watching kilwa kill
heartbreaking because he seems to do it
with such reluctance
and vocal hesitance a testament to the
voice acting and storytelling
in action he does what must be done and
we don't know how he feels about it
afterwards because we switch
perspectives
i use the word wonderful to describe
this moment too in its
literal sense of the word the switch
that is flicked when he's actively
trying to kill fills me with wonder
the art style in these moments that is
so purely his it's such a sharp shift
from
the heart eyes he lays upon gone and i
wonder whether we'll see a situation in
which he goes
to that place in order to save god's
life or if the engagement of that state
of mind is the
shutting down of all emotion fequila his
eyes certainly went dead when he
realized he needed to kill
losing their pupils and studying his
prey to a large degree
kilowatt's family unit all fit the molds
of these insects and their hive
minds it doesn't matter that his family
isn't physically there in the moment
they trained him to do a task and he did
it with all the cleanliness expected of
his family line when we think of how
kilwa was shackled up the comparison of
the queen ant and her home to the
mountain of his is
actually quite concerningly familiar and
i do wonder whether there's something in
those two styles being similar
that humans have made the chimera ants
more evil makes me wonder what could
happen if a zoldic were consumed
whether kilwa would be able to sink into
that assassin form and clear his mind of
any connection to them however tenuous
gone meanwhile showed us that he can do
more than bash things with
rock now he can slice him up with
scissors and since that's the direction
we're going here i wonder what will be
his paper and how that will come into
effect
we don't see the two training we simply
see these new abilities and while i like
the mild surprise on my end that comes
from seeing him slice a many limbed bug
in two i'm constantly in a state of
wondering whether they have shown these
abilities to each other and if so
whether they can be used together ah
that reminds me kewar mentioned that his
transmuture ability tires him
does that imply his assassin abilities
have absolutely nothing to do with nen
i mean obviously he learned them
beforehand but no crossover since
i'm gonna keep on the lookout for more
information there because the abilities
shown by every other nen user that i can
think of in my
limited memory capacity suggest that
their abilities interact with each other
to create a seamless whole
kiwah is still two people the one he
wants to be
and the dark one he is who he lets out
to play sometimes
whether or not he gets a choice speaking
of dark i'm starting to see these taboo
things getting stronger and stronger
forcing people to walk on their elbows
is not the best way to make sure
everyone's having fun when it comes to
things that people define as dark my
question is always
okay but is it gratuitous torture for
the sake of torture grossness or nudity
or sex just for the sake of it it
reminds me of those eggs who voguen had
to pass through his apparently giant
schlong
that was unnecessarily gross like it was
just gross here the torture destruction
and humiliation of human life is
actually surprisingly clear
it also serves a purpose gone reacted
gone reacts human life has a value to
him and that's
you know what that's a really positive
thing for our kid i'm happy about that
the problem is that the longer he's in
this environment the less i think it's
going to matter hunter hunter's sort of
a search for his lost humanity which
it turns out is right behind him and
fading the longer he looks for it
for all that he sat on the ground and
considered who should live or die in
episode 3 he's
about to be making those decisions now
and it'll be interesting to see what his
choices become
and as for kite the more he describes
his random clown friend the more i'm
expecting him to reveal that it's jing
who told him to take the ability because
that's the sort of thing he'd do
meanwhile i ask again because these are
the important questions
where are these bugs getting these
outfits at first i thought
nah it's probably just leftovers from
the people they've snatched but when you
see
bug lady wearing the revealing bra skirt
combo that looks like none of the
clothing the villagers would have worn
and now i'm imagining the ngl dining up
their special lingerie which you know
power to him and finally sing us a song
you're the bunny man
he's got himself some men i don't recall
him eating someone
enticing does that mean he's developed
it himself
how does this work i suppose there are
some with latent nen and getting broken
down by the boys as led to him being
activated
does this mean nene ant can become
an end-user something about him reminds
me of hiskey
hiskey but not cool or impressive i
don't know something like that
anyway we'll see i guess let's take a
look at episode
83. some interesting things happened in
this episode but it's going to be
sort of hard to discuss and break down
because i feel
as though i don't have enough context
for them and some of them are
really philosophical ideas that are in
my head what i do have context for is
the anxiety and tension in my entire
body
for the entire time the ladybugs were
flying
around the city it's sort of like the
vashta narada from doctor who which is
one of my favorite monsters and the idea
behind them is that you don't need to
fear every shadow but you
fear because it could be any shadow that
could kill you
the same applies here and taps into a
deep generic feeling of disconcertedness
that spreads through people's lives
it is not every bug most bugs will be
bugs but it could be
any bug and that's the scary thing there
could be any number of queen ants out
there who are
just not her size and they could be
spreading information through the city
the fact that there are so many
specifically
ladybugs actually makes that more likely
since tagashi either
likes to flag things really early on or
just red hairing them and i'm
i'm just you know tense the problem is
that we know that bugs could be in any
form and we've seen the level of
individuality in this
colony and thinking about the kinds of
animal mixes we have seen
we have penguin peggy and little kitty
lion dude who's not little but like you
know
kitty he's got the cute little tattoo
scentsy
i don't know what they are but they're
cute you know if their planet has the
same poles and the same weather type as
ours
lions and penguins do not come from
anywhere near each other this queen has
traveled yes queen
if another queen hadn't but had a lot of
ladybugs available to her well
ladybugs are plenty i was surprised that
despite being bug people and despite
knowing that the insect creation could
come from any bug
bubble gum didn't kill it and yeah sure
that's probably me being paranoid but
it's actually only paranoia if bugs
aren't out to kill you and eat you so
the tension of that entire scene had me
fearing for big metropolises
which the colony have yet to come into
contact with
something i didn't understand was why it
would be bad to exterminate the colony
now that it's causing danger to human
life why would the hunters be to blame
in the world that we have here if
something is causing
uh genuine harm to humans we tend to
prioritize that
what is different in their society that
says don't do that
given the size and power and the danger
they're posing wouldn't the intention
be to get rid of as many as possible why
would the hunters be to blame for it i
think i'm really missing something here
so i'm not gonna go
into it what i am hoping and expecting
to be honest is that
hiskey and bunny boy ramot will get to
play oh
i know who ramon reminds me of it's not
just
hiskey he reminds me of jace from dragon
ball z
all that posturing and grandstanding i
just wanted to appear behind him and
just slap him upside the head
once he punched colt in the face and
frankly it's a testament to
colt's buggy self that he still has a
face i simply didn't need any more of
ramot doing ramu stuff i'm ready for him
to engage in some form of action rather
than just bouncing around and
showing off his bunny muscles so while i
understand that peggy was having a
moment discussing the situation my
attention wandered until the story began
to move on
what i did take in and what is
interesting
is that latent men can come from
physical harm
does that mean gone and kilowatt have
merged with the bugs given gone's
reaction at the end of the episode i
wonder if the experience was actually
mutual
gone would be a fantastic addition to
the queen's army he'd essentially be
cult 2.0
that said the concern kite is feeling
around gone wanting to kill those who
are traitorous to their kind is
incredibly valid what will gon do when
he meets cult
he won't kill him he can't not with his
own points of view and
and morals and stuff his weird morals i
don't where did he get
morals from and more to the point it
looks like he
does have morals did he actually kill
was it that
understated and no it was a combat
sequence and it had its own weight but i
guess i expected him to have more to
deal with or
no i expect no i guess i expected
us to have more time and space to deal
with
the fallout of that gon could casually
kill the armadillo boy because army boy
was mean to his friends
essentially friendship even the
declaration of it can have a very
powerful effect on gon
things in people with connections to
other things and people seem to be
sacred to him
the second those concepts are violated
it seems that god no longer sees them as
deserving of life or
deserving of existence i suppose the
interesting thing about this colony and
its development is that they
seem to be showing more individualism
than we humans do the development of
their society seems to be fracturing and
crumbling faster than i'd have expected
it to
the captains are losing control of their
basic military at an exceedingly rapid
pace and i don't know that it has to do
with the
numbers of different creatures so much
as the fact that they've managed to dial
up the self-importance to an extreme
amount where survival should be the
first concern
of animals i mean even for humans
survival is the first concern it's the
first thing we worry about
and that self-importance is probably
going to be their downfall they're
starting to lose their bugness in the
characterization and that doesn't
really make a great deal of sense to me
given a lot of the ants we're following
are from the same generation and i am
totally overthinking this from a human
development perspective but that's kind
of the discussion
and thought that takashi seems to be
trying to get us to engage in what
is humanity how does it develop what
happens when it's challenged is
humanity fundamentally right or wrong
does it matter
is humanity individuality or does that
behavior come from independent other
creatures
too how are these characters influenced
by the blends of
animal they are i mean a cat leading a
pride for instance that makes sense
i don't understand bunny boy but was he
broken by that run-in with gun and
killer or
elevated are they the same thing being
broken and
elevated is that are they the same thing
and they're all themes that i've been
considering as this arc progresses
i have so many thoughts at the end of
this episode and that's all they can be
philosophy is annoying because it rarely
has answers but it poses so many
questions and maybe we'll get some
answers next episode such as
why kite has an ability he hates but
we're not going to get it now because
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this journey through my
mind and want to hear more
click here here and or here don't forget
to like and subscribe and i'll see you
next time